[Musique]
les résidents de Saint-Roch de la chigan
répondent présents
a senti le besoin de s'unir cette messe
de solidarité a été organisée rapidement
pour aider la communauté si c'est serré
à traverser cette épreuve pour passer à
travers des difficultés des épreuves on
a besoin de cette présence on a besoin
de l'amour des autres au bout de la rue
principale les véhicules de la Sûreté du
Québec nous rappellent que tout n'est
pas encore élucidé au sujet de la
déflagration de jeudi trois jours après
le drame le périmètre de sécurité est
toujours érigé et l'enquête pourrait
prendre une autre tournure Radio-Canada
a pris que la Sûreté du Québec veut
vérifier s'il n'y aurait pas eu
négligence criminelle des travaux
étaient en cours lorsque l'explosion est
survenue chez propane la fortune et la
police soupçonne des émissions
sur les lieux pour essayer de voir où et
quoi et dans quel état est-il
au moment où elle saisit mais comment
fonctionne-t-il au préalable au moment
des opérations depuis jeudi dans notre
famille
il manque du monde les élus également
ébranlés par notre j'ai dit espère que
les policiers iront au fond de la faire
on laisse vraiment la sortie du Québec
procéder à ses faux et ses recherches
comprendrez que la scène est
relativement complexe donc le temps de
faire les vérifications nécessaires je
pense c'est important c'est important
pour tout le monde qui s'ouvre la
possibilité d'une enquête pour
négligence criminelle ben c'est
peut-être simplement
prudent de le faire et de regarder
toutes les facettes de l'événement les
responsables de l'entreprise n'ont pas
voulu commenter expliquant que la
journée était dédiée aux proches des
deux employés et du sous-traitant qui
manque toujours à l'appel ici Carla
Oliveira Radio-Canada Saint-Roch de la
chica